in the last two years israel has been
thrown into a political whirlpool
one election cycle after another four
campaigns within two years
no one managed to form a long-lasting
coalition
and benjamin netanyahu elected prime
minister in 2009
has managed to stay in power
and then came these two the up and
coming duo of naphtali bennett and jai
lapid have already collaborated in the
past
but now their partnership seemed to have
done the inconceivable
ansi netanyahu from premiership after 12
years in power
a former director general of the
settlers lobby organization yesha
council
bennett is considered a right-wing
nationalist leader lapid on the other
hand
is a former news anchor and the son of a
holocaust survivor and he finds himself
as a centrist
where do bennett and lapid the
politicians who aspire to lead israel
for the foreseeable future
stand on key issues their interviews on
conflict zone from 2015 and 2017 can
give us a clue
the big picture is that we're in our
jewish home here
okay it's been our jewish home for about
3800 years
even in the arab world they know now
that there's no way of going
back to 1967 or to 1948.
we things have changed despite coming
from two opposing political blocs they
actually
are not too far apart what do they have
in common and where do they disagree
join us as we dig into the conflict zone
archive to learn more about the views
they expressed in the past
and more importantly how that might
affect their actions in the future
[Music]
a long-term solution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict is one of
the most contested issues between
bennett and lepid
what will the new government mean for
palestinian statehood
you gave an interview last year you were
asked about the freeze in the peace
prosperous a freeze that you supported
you said the process
was suicide we saved the country
looking at the violence today it doesn't
look as though you saved the country at
all does it
well tim you know for the past 100 years
we've had
roughly 40 rounds of violence with the
radical islam in 1921 1929
1936 1939 that's the whole point it's
not getting better
this is nothing new and until the muslim
world
accepts israel's right to exist and we
we were here way before
the islam even started it it will go on
but you know what
amid all this turbulence israel is
growing
israel is thriving as are its people so
i'm very optimistic and you want
separation
this is your policy separation to bring
about the jewish majority
that you want in israel your policy is
to separate from the politicians
what if large numbers don't want to
separate what are you going to do
forcible removal
no anyway we'll be talking you're asking
if we will do anything that is
unilateral i don't think so i don't
think it's the right move i think you
don't think so
i think we're not going to do it no
we're not going to do anything
unilateral we tried that in the
disengagement as
i said before and it didn't work out
that well i'm not suggesting to form a
palestinian state in the midst of israel
i think that would be a profound mistake
i uh vehemently oppose the notion of
forming another
failed arab state in the heart of israel
that's crazy
all the rest are falling apart and
disintegrating into tribal uh
structures so here we're going to try
another artificial one
why do i want to commit suicide more
than 130 countries have recognized
at the un have recognized palestine as a
state
and you want the palestinians to give up
forever
on this idea of a palestinian state
you're too late aren't you
no i'm not you know way too late let me
tell you something i have four children
a ten-year-old eight-year-old six and
three we live just 10 minutes from the
proposed palestinian state
if we were to form a palestinian state
according to these 130 countries
and place a radical islamic state just
10 minutes from my house
i would put my children under harm's way
it doesn't have to be arrested
for islam it's not going to happen does
it have to be
in la la land it's not in reality it is
because we're not living in a soap opera
tim
we live in israel we live in the heart
of the
toughest place in the world what i'm
saying is you know you may not like the
partner but you have to work with what
it is
i wish we had i think zakarbin said that
before me i wish we had the conflict
with the swedes
then we can solve it much pretty in in
in much easier fashion
we have we have a dispute with the
palestinians and we have to separate
from the palestinians and build the
highest world possible
you said in january last year if i was
prime minister tomorrow that's a deal i
would make
building in the blocks in malayam ariel
gushetzian in exchange for a freeze
outside the block
true but do you think the world is going
to buy this
yes why why because all the settlements
are still seen as illegal
they're two theories in the outside
world all of them whether they're in the
block or right now two theories one that
is considering
the entire settlement so the entire
territories is the one thing and one of
the same there's a difference
things have happened this is the bush on
letter from 2001
saying there is a difference between the
big blocks and because between what is
happening outside the big blocks what is
happening
outside the big blocks is probably the
future state of palestine
inside the big blocks is israel isn't
going to stay israel and that's let's
not pretend it's the same
both bennett and lapid see hamas as a
destructive force in the gaza
strip will they manage to form a new
solution to this persistent challenge
we have done in gaza whatever
the world has ever asked us to do we
left
we dismantled the settlements
let me finish let me finish and you know
what we even left them with 3 000
greenhouses for them to build an economy
for themselves
and instead of doing so they have built
training camps for the islamic jihad and
fired
until this moment more than fifteen
thousand rockets on our children
and you've blockaded him since 2007 and
you don't even
yes and we're protecting ourselves
are we not allowed to protect the life
of our children is this something only
the other side has
the right to what is happening is people
are using
or misusing should i say all the rights
that are being given
in order to promote terror so if you're
allowing them to do
all sorts of moving movements in gaza
each and every time they've misused in
2005 we did the big experiment in gaza
we did all three things the
international community wanted we pulled
back to the 67 lines
we pulled out all our soldiers and you
know what we expelled
8 000 jews from their home by force and
what did we get
days after and you're still controlling
everything that moves into gaza
that's
it was going to be the singapore of the
middle east it was open but then
no with you know
besides the fact that you're stating
wrong facts everything's okay
the reality is quite the contrary when
we gave them gaza
we said go build a singapore and you
wanna you know what
they shot thousands of missiles from
there onto israel which is why yes we
need to defend ourselves
what do you do when every centimeter of
land that you hand
the radical islamists turns into a base
of iran and radical islam what do you do
with the world's eyes on jerusalem a
bennett lapid government will aspire to
maintain the status quo in the israeli
capital
but will they manage to keep the city
peaceful the only place
in the middle east that exercises full
religious rights for all religions
christian christianity
and muslims and jews as israel so no one
should tell us
uh how to govern temple mount temple
mount is open for muslims
to pray and the roughly two and a half
muslims have prayed
at temple mount in the past year while
only about twelve thousand jews that's
just let's put things in proportion and
that's also and there's a large
amount of rabbinical advice on this
and views that says jews should not
actually pray
on the temple mount you know now you're
representing the rabbis
that's a whole new that's a whole new
you know this this is the status quo
isn't it that jews do not
by and large pray at the time i don't
dispute the status quo it will go on
penitent lapid have phoned what they
call a government of healing which has
made history by bringing in
an arab party was that move motivated by
ideology or political necessity
i think israel is a jewish state i think
part of being a jewish state and a
jewish democracy
is making sure the minorities will have
their rights the larger issue
and this is something that your
president has drawn attention to
he says israel is sick with racism these
are his words
he said last year he's also horrified by
the thuggishness
that's permeated the national dialogue
why don't you speak out about that
i will you know we have one and a half
million arabs living in israel
they exercise full equal rights they
have enjoyed
all the privileges that every jew they
vote for the president says there's
no discrimination i think there are many
people in this country who said racist
things
what you want me to defend now every
israeli i'm out there
i'm fighting racism in this country i
fight fight i'm fighting prejudice in
this country
i did things for the arab citizens of
this country
and i will fight for their right for for
the equal rights whenever i can i always
believe reality is stronger than any
words
you know you know very well that one and
a half million israeli arabs
vote for the knesset they pay taxes in
israel that's the reality
there's no place better on earth for
arabs
than in israel we have to realize that
no one's going anywhere the jews are
here to stay the arabs are here to stay
we have to live together